something i feel like you've done a good
job of doing in la is working with a
wide spectrum of
artists here and i want to say you were
kind of like the class before
um the ruchi's and the chikes and those
guys like you were active before them in
the music game but
i kind of feel like you are a part of
that initial class that was like
not as divided as we've seen la be in
the past
yeah definitely and
with la hip-hop there's always politics
no matter what happens right yeah for
sure and
you know we've seen street politics
equal artists that want to work with
each other not working with each other
in the past for sure you know what i
mean like i remember talking to q about
like why you never work with dipsy and
it's obvious right yeah um but at the
same time like i feel like the new
generation of los angeles artists
to a higher extent than i've ever seen
at least
have
done a great job of either putting that
stuff to the side and working together
or just automatically just tapping in
with each other now obviously there's
always going to be some drama you know
what i'm saying but what is it about la
right now that you feel like
has a
a real united feel to it
um
you know naturally this is the gang city
the gang culture so
like you said it's uh
you know people that i run with might
not get along with you know people that
i want to work with around with but
what's going on right now was like
a lot of the artists that's up and
coming not really
gang affiliated
to a certain extent you know what i mean
right a lot of people didn't they didn't
grow up gangbanging or don't really have
like the
the super gang bangers around in the mix
and this is it's just a lot more players
a lot more people about their money
you know i'm seeing in the [ __ ] and i
think it's dope you know what i'm saying
um
i actually was tripping one day when i
when i noticed what was going on i'm
like [ __ ] everybody working together and
there's no problems you know what i'm
saying which is like
never happened out here hopefully it'll
keep going but hopefully it keeps going
uh
it's just like you know um
a lot of people were able to look past
it and then a lot of people like not
wrapped up in the gang [ __ ] so deep that
you know they letting that [ __ ] hinder
whatever happened i wish i was that good
you know what i'm saying i'm like
i'm tied into this [ __ ] like certain
people i'm never gonna work with like
and they might be cool or whatnot but
it's just like
just like where i come from and the [ __ ]
that i believe in it's like
you know it is or i just got to just
know that a person is genuine you know
what i'm saying because i don't want to
be doing music with somebody and then
later on they cool with me but they own
some [ __ ] this in my hood or something
like you know so i think that's what
stopped a lot of [ __ ] previously and
what's bringing [ __ ] together is
like [ __ ] not really like
yeah like you'll talk to like like kids
and they'll be like yo like i really
didn't grow up that way my uncles were
or you know i grew up in that area but
like i wasn't active so it's a lot
easier for me to reach across the aisle
and work with you know exactly and
that's dope you know what i'm saying
because a lot of you know like over the
years a lot of people didn't a lot of
people from the previous time didn't
grow up gang banging but you know for
that image
and that certain thing and the
surrounding people
like they let that [ __ ] hinder [ __ ] like
you know it's a lot of it's
i can't really name too many artists
from los angeles right like in the lab
even in the last 10 years that actually
really grew up gang banging you know i'm
saying like or in the mix you know i'm
saying but you know [ __ ] is
affiliated and
you know the image and the people around
[ __ ] [ __ ] up i mean yeah it doesn't hurt
record sales for people to believe
you're a gang member oh that [ __ ] is
great especially for la artists like
that's what this [ __ ] is about like yeah
just the land of the gang bang